okay so there are there are a lot of
little easter eggs and that kind of
stuff but nothing too pivotal when it
comes to this uh there is a fun little
easter egg in relation to classic x-men
issue number 43 that we're going to talk
about but i do also want to talk about
jake lockley because i think i know how
jake lockley is going gonna manifest and
i think
i think they told us that jake lockley
had manifested somewhere along the line
they just didn't tell us directly right
so here's the thing let's start with the
reference to classic x-men issue number
43. so the the cool thing about this is
in marvel comics we've got a video
explaining that the comics explained
right so uh that video is far more
in-depth this one's going to be pretty
short and gritty uh but the whole idea
behind this is that when it comes to
like the realm of the afterlife that's a
fairly new thing that in marvel comics
way back in the day all you really had
in terms of the afterlife was like the
realm of hella and that was basically it
because back in the 1960s in the early
1970s all you really had were like the
tales of asgard written and drawn by
jack kirby which gave us like the
backstory of asgard right how it was
created and how odin rose to power and
the early days of thor and all that kind
of stuff it's interesting if you care
about the history of asgard it's not if
you don't
but in those early days the only
afterlife was the realm of hella that
when a person died who did not die in
like honorable combat they went to the
realm of hell which was not really a
place where you burned for eternity it
was just the afterlife in general and
that those individuals who died in
honorable combat would go to valhalla if
they were allowed in right they'd be
taken there by the valkyries and that
kind of a thing but all this changed in
the mid 1970s with the introduction of
mistress death and the reason why was
because at the time with thanos being
accompanied by mistress death and
basically that being his basis for being
a nihilist right that life is
meaningless and always wanting the the
affection of mistress death and so on
and so forth that what this did is it
led to marvel having to offer an
explanation of how mistress death fits
into like the concept of the afterlife
and so depending on what story you're
reading they've said that like hella is
actually an aspect of mistress death and
other stories they're like no hell is
her own person right she does her own
thing it depends on what you want on how
you want to interpret it but the notion
of the afterlife in relation to mistress
death was brought full force in classic
x-men issue number 43 that what this did
is it was basically a part of the
original dark phoenix saga but the
classic x-men stories were basically
reprints of x-men runs from like chris
claremont but new information was added
in and so what they did is they had a
moment where jean grey had kind of died
but not really when she was the white
phoenix and actually traveled to the
realm of mistress death and she kind of
helped mistress death build her own
realm out to a little to a little bit
and ended up building this pillar and
when she did she saw light on the inside
of it and when she looked in she saw
memories right she basically saw like
her own experiences and that's when she
realized oh my god i'm in the realm of
mistress death and so what we got in
terms of this explanation is like each
one of these little pillars that exists
out there is basically a person's
individual afterlife that unlike what
you saw at the end of moon night where
like mark specter quote-unquote passes
on and ends up in the land of reeds that
it's not some gigantic ethereal place
where seemingly everybody hangs out that
the realm of mistress death is a place
where when you die you go there and then
you experience your own individual
afterlife which is likely populated by
the people you've known over the course
of your life or maybe you just relive a
sequence of memories for all eternity
hopefully the best ones uh and then like
that's basically it following that
marvel started introducing people like
mephisto and things along those lines so
like if you're some poor bastard who
makes a deal with mephisto and doesn't
realize what it is that you're doing
when you die you go to his his section
of hell because like he has his section
damon hellstrom has his section all
those different people out there have
their own individual sections of hell
and so uh so that's kind of how the
afterlife functions now one of the other
cool references that i did love in this
episode was the reference to the
ancestral plane because that's kind of
like okay cool so like they're
referencing black panther uh that's
awesome like it's it's cool to see that
so i i imagine that going forward
they'll probably have more references to
like the various places of death that
you would call it of course this really
begs the question when are we going to
get a reference to mephisto's section of
hell it would have been cool if they had
dropped that right where she had been
like there's a lot of different places
that are out there just be glad you're
not going to to like the realm of
mephisto that place is awful from what
i've heard like that would have just
been like just
right like the internet would have
exploded uh if that were the case so
they had like referenced that i'm so
disappointed they're not but this goes
into kind of tying the classic x-men and
the moon knight thing together so the
point that i'm making here is that in
this episode when steve grant and and
mark spector were kind of going through
and reliving each other's memories that
this was in a lot of ways referencing
the classic x-men source material right
from classic x-men issue number 43. is
it an exact copy not really but there
aren't very many stories and i can't
really think of any off the top of my
head i'm not saying they don't exist i
just can't think of any off top my head
uh where this exact form and function is
followed outside of classic x-men issue
number 43 so it is cool to see that like
they're referencing source material
outside of the moon night stuff and then
adapting it to moon knight itself but
what i do want to talk about here is i
want to talk about jake lockley because
i think they told us the first time jake
lockley manifested so here's the thing
in the point where you have the episode
where uh or at least a point in the
episode when you when like they're
looking through the window and you see
like the body of mark specter that's
just standing outside that car and
shrieking alcohol i thought that was
jake lockley initially i was like oh my
god it's jake lockley now of course it's
not it's basically mark spector just
avoiding his mother's funeral and of
course he turns into steve grant and
says like you know this was the first
time our lives started bleeding over and
all that kind of stuff but
i think that they told us exactly when
jake lockley first appeared so like
follow the sequence of events when it
comes to mark spector's life right that
mark spector had taken his younger
brother rorro into a cave when it was
raining and they weren't supposed to go
in there and his younger brother drowned
following that his mom basically started
abusing him and tearing him down because
she saw mark spector as being the reason
for why her his younger brother died in
the first place so all her anger and
vengeance was taken out on him and so
during that time when she was physically
abusing him and emotionally abusing him
that mark spector's mind fractured that
he quite literally created the steve
grant persona now from a from an
official diagnostic standpoint when it
comes to disassociative identity
disorder i'm not really qualified to
state whether or not that's actually
that's how it actually happens my
basic reading uh has really introduced
me to the idea that usually multiple
personalities manifest or splinter
personalities manifest as a result of
extreme trauma right that the only way
the brain can process that trauma is to
create a personality that doesn't have
to deal with it and so that's how you
supposedly end up with a disassociative
identity disorder i don't know if that's
true again i'm not qualified to like
explicitly state that but
what i do think happened here is while
mark spector was aware of the the abuse
that he was experiencing at the hands of
his mother and that while the steve
grant persona was created to basically
create a better life for himself where
he never had to experience that and he
grew up believing that like his mom's
alive and his mom loved him and his
family life was great and all that kind
of stuff i think the jake jake lockley
personality was growing and brewing i
don't think it was ever i don't think it
ever appeared i don't think it ever like
manifested in any meaningful way
until the death of mark spector's mom
because as far as i'm aware they didn't
tell us how she died and it wouldn't
surprise me one bit if the jake lockley
persona given what we've seen so far
that it's not some cab driver who exists
out there with his ear to the ground
that's the marvel comics version i think
the jake lockley persona is much darker
and i think the jake lockley persona is
far more violent that i think what
happened is that the jake lockley
persona is the result of all the abuse
that mark specter uh basically
experienced at the hands of his mom it's
just outright rage right the living
embodiment of vengeance like that's what
uh what the jake lockley persona is and
that there came a point when mark was
experiencing abuse at the hands of his
mom when perhaps he intentionally or
unintentionally thought he was switching
over to the steve grant persona and the
jake lockley persona manifested and
killed his mom and that's how she died
right that was it maybe jake locally
made it look like an accident or
whatever the case is and the only time
that jake lockley persona manifests is
when the situation is so extreme that
the life of
basically all three is in danger right
the lives of steve grant and mark
spector and jake locklear in danger
because somebody's gonna kill their
physical body and that steve grant and
mark spector can't handle it the jake
lockley persona manifest takes control
deals with the situation and leaves and
the reason why i say that is from a
mental health perspective when you're a
little kid and you're being abused by
your parent that what it does is it
kicks your brain into a fight-or-flight
mode right like you literally feel like
your life is in jeopardy you take that
concept and you apply it to the the
episode where like they were being
attacked by the henchmen and like when
when what is it uh steve grant came to
that the henchmen were basically in the
process of being killed by him and mark
specter's like that wasn't me like i
don't know who that was but like that
wasn't me that it was jake lockley who
did that and that now when you have the
end of this episode and what you have is
mark spector out there in the land of
reeds and you've got steve grant who's
just locked in the sand right out there
in the duat there's nobody else to
basically seize control of the body of
of mark specter
except for jake lockley and so i think
jake lockley that persona is gonna step
in and that persona like episode six is
when we're gonna see him for the first
time and this dude's gonna be crazy like
it's gonna be wild how how just capable
this guy is that he's probably gonna be
exceedingly dangerous and yeah like
things are gonna pop off again i don't
definitively know this this is just a
theory that i have right i mean outside
of just sort of linking some things
together which may have no connection
whatsoever i'm just sort of throwing it
out there so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments right i mean
do you think this is what's gonna happen
do you think that like the jake lockley
persona was born of like mark spector's
mom's abuse and like jake lockley killed
mark spector's mom and that he only ever
comes out every once in a while because
from what we saw right the only real
little moment that we saw which was
seemingly jake lockley where he was
locked in the casket dude was beaten on
that thing for dear life screaming and
carrying on all that kind of stuff dude
seemed hyper violent right so like maybe
that's the case maybe that's what's
going on because i gotta say man if that
really is what jake lockley is right
where mark spector's just the kid who
dealt with all the abuse and steve grant
is the one that never had to experience
it and that jake lockley is all of mark
spector's mom's abuse manifested in a
physical in like a mental form
i can't imagine all the rage and like
just anguish and pain that guy brings to
the table man because then then you got
to ask the question what happens when he
comes bringing that pain and anguish
down on arthur harrow that's the
question you gotta ask man that dude's
gonna rue the day
he's going to rue the day that he messes
with mark spector man it's going to be
an abs man it's going to be a bloodbath
but let me know what you guys think
right let me know anything down in the
comment section thank you all for
watching i will catch you all later
peace